[Música]
durante el Mundial de fútbol en Qatar
las noticias falsas se han ido a jugar
la prórroga la redacción de los
observadores de France 24 seleccionó
varias de estas imágenes y denuncias que
en algunos de los casos son
injustificadas empezamos con esta
publicación después del partido de Japón
contra Costa Rica el pasado 27 de
noviembre Japón perdió 1 por 0 Y así fue
como el equipo supuestamente había
dejado sus vestidores en un estado
lamentable pero esta publicación es una
noticia falsa inicialmente Era una broma
en tono de parodia que algunas personas
Se tomaron en serio En realidad estas
fotos son de otro vestidor el de Italia
después de su derrota 1 por 0 contra
macedonia del Norte en marzo pasado fru
por este fracaso que los dejó por fuera
del mundial de Qatar al irse Los
italianos dejaron los vestidores del
estadio de Palermo en condiciones
lamentables de hecho es todo lo
contrario el equipo japonés es conocido
por dejar sus vestidores impecables
después de cada partido Esta es la
verdadera foto del vestidor de Japón
después de su derrota contra Costa Rica
y otra tomada después de su eliminación
en octavos de final contra Croacia el 5
de diciembre es también el caso de Los
hinchas japoneses que suelen limpiar las
gradas después de los partidos segundo
ejemplo de noticia falsa con este video
según esta publicación de tiktok el
video mostraría un rezo en uno de los
estadios de Qatar durante el Mundial
recibió más de 800.000 me gusta y fue
compartido aproximadamente 38 mil veces
El problema es que las tribunas de ese
estadio se lee kazán y kazán es la
capital de la República rusa de
tatarstán y es el centro político y
cultural de la comunidad musulmana en
Rusia el video se remonta a mayo del
2019 se había organizado allí rezos en
ese estadio en Rusia por la ruptura del
ayuno del ramadán Así que la publicación
No tiene nada que ver con el mundial de
Qatar pero atención Eso no significa que
no haya escenas similares a las afueras
de los estadios cataríes a menudo ha
habido rezos al margen de los partidos
del Mundial como se ve por ejemplo en
este vídeo grabado el 5 de diciembre y
terminamos con esta foto aficionados del
equipo de Francia sostienen una bufanda
con una gran falta de ortografía se lee
fons en vez de fans que sería la forma
correcta de escribir el nombre de este
país en francés el mensaje detrás de
esta publicación es que esos hinchas ni
siquiera saben escribir en francés
porque serían aficionados falsos es
también una referencia a una polémica
que surgió a comienzos del mundial en la
que Qatar fue acusado de haber hecho
desfilar aficionados falsos por las
calles a cambio de dinero pero esta foto
es de nuevo una noticia falsa es posible
comprobarlo con una herramienta que
detecta las manipulaciones gráficas se
ve que la o y la s aparecen en rojo lo
que sugiere un fotomontaje para estar
completamente seguros basta con hacer
una búsqueda inversa de imágenes aparece
la foto en su contexto original y se ve
que la palabra France está bien escrita
en la bufanda once en francés esta
noticia falsa que pretendía ser
divertida no le hizo gracia a todo el
mundo hablamos con uno de los
aficionados indios del equipo francés
que aparecen en esta foto viajó
especialmente desde el estado de querala
Para apoyar a los azules
después de toda la pasión que hemos
demostrado por el equipo de Francia el
resultado es que todo el mundo nos ve
como aficionados falsos
se podrán imaginar cómo nos sentimos
los franceses deberían estar orgullosos
de tener hinchas fuera de su país
debería sentirse orgullosos en vez de
crear trolls en vez de crear este tipo
de noticias falsas como ven compartir de
manera inocente una noticia falsa puede
herir a las personas involucradas
entonces si usted tiene alguna duda
antes de compartir puede enviarnos la
foto o el video a nuestra cuenta de
Twitter arroba info-intox f24 para que
nosotros la verifiquemos
[Música]
logro es el apodo de este elefante que a
finales de noviembre llegó hasta los
alrededores del pueblo de chevlogé en
Costa de Marfil los habitantes ya lo
bautizaron porque lo conocen muy bien el
animal suele ir a menudo y se deja tocar
sin ningún tipo de problema algunos
incluso consideran que sería la
reencarnación de alguno de sus ancestros
estas imágenes pueden parecer muy
simpáticas pero le preocupan a nuestro
observador quien fue el que grabó estas
imágenes una de las razones principales
que hace que los elefantes los animales
vengan al pueblo es porque ya no tienen
hábitat cuando el hábitat natural queda
destruido ya no saben a dónde ir ya no
saben dónde vivir no pueden vivir en paz
entonces están obligados a ir en
búsqueda de comida al pueblo porque los
árboles frutales de los que solían
alimentarse se han muerto
fueron destruidos para sembrar cultivos
en Costa de Marfil es muy raro ver un
elefante acercarse a la población
los niños se suben encima de él se
sientan sobre su espalda
bien al pueblo y le dan comida le dan
agua y cuando queda satisfecho regresa a
la selva cada año es igual entre el 2016
y el 2020 otro elefante marfileño
llamado acmed había estado en contacto
regular con la población el paquidermo
se había separado de su manada al
principio era bastante juguetón pero
después terminó por Mostrar signos de
agresividad destruyendo varios vehículos
y Campos a pesar de haber sido
trasladado a una reserva en el 2020 su
comportamiento no evolucionó en Costa de
Marfil la población de elefantes ha
disminuido drásticamente los últimos 30
años pasando de 1.100 a menos de 500 la
causa la deforestación pero también la
casa ilegal
el elefante logró estar en peligro
porque es dócil y tranquilo
entonces eso hace que los cazadores
ilegales puedan acercarse a él para
hacerle daño como ven Esta es una selva
donde incluso hay monos
pero actualmente en Man
las autoridades han tomado medidas para
proteger esta selva Porque si es
destruida imagínense estos monos se van
a dispersar por la naturaleza y los
cazadores ilegales los van a exterminar
lo que la población quiere es que el
elefante esté seguro
y que se ha llevado a un parque a una
reserva donde sea posible acercarse a él
es todo por esta semana si usted quiere
ser parte de nuestra red de observadores
envíenos todas sus historias videos e
imágenes a los contactos que aparecen en
sus pantallas nosotros nos vemos en una
próxima oportunidad Hasta pronto
[Música]